hello everybody I was about to be like
hey hey I know I'm sorry it's just a
force of habit but we can't say that
anymore yeah we get in big trouble Yujin
doesn't like when we say cuss words in
the first like minute of the video they
not only do they do monetize it a lot of
the times which I won't show you the
video in algorithm they suppress the
videos too and when they don't like
what's going on in the first minute of
the video sex BIG's Big D's yeah because
of that suppression we're making some
were making some big changes you guys
big changes as you could see from the
set yeah there's gonna be a whole
rebranding coming soon 2020 baby
tune in for it we're here for it we're
living for it yeah yeah you guys so much
for tuning in all of 2018 we love you
guys so much we've had a great fun year
we're excited yes and because love it so
much there's the big changes that we
keep talking about and there's gonna be
more of that coming your way but because
there's gonna be more of that another
big rebranding that's happening is this
face right here it's gonna be lessened
on this show ya know but it's all in
good spirit because it's gonna be for
the person you guys all love you guys
all love Tyga and I'm gonna do this so
because all of your energy parasite he
is but he's giving me so much life yeah
and that's something that I always
wanted that sounded so corny oh but I
swear to God I sort of got that like
that but you want to be a mom I love it
yes and I've always said that you guys
have always heard me talk about just
wanting a mom hard so I finally get to
do that but the beautiful thing about
that is I get to mom hard while these
ladies are gonna continue to lady
freaking hard
lady damn hard be hard this is going but
yeah I'll definitely drop a drop in from
time to time so I'm not completely
online disappearing but you'll see less
of me yeah but we're gonna have
way more stuff for you guys it's gonna
be really cool
you're gonna want to watch tuned in to
see the rest of the changes we can't
tell you yet we can't tell you yet but
it's big but it's big it's huge barely
take it I'm gonna take it please enjoy
this episode was about I hope you like
it
hello hey [ __ ] hey [ __ ] hey do me
[ __ ] another episode and today we
wanted to talk about just like toxic
relationships breakups whether it be a
romantic breakup or a friendship breakup
but why we decided to cut those people
out of our lives and just like in
general I think a state of maturing as a
person is you learn like what you no
longer stand for anymore yeah so what's
some [ __ ] that you don't have time for
anymore with other people oh my gosh so
much mm-hmm people who whine a lot only
I can be the person that makes two of us
true I am I briefly dated a dude where
every time you got mad he went ooh Oh
like hey it was brief yeah it was very
party caught my eye twitching just
thinking about it it got to the point
where like towards the end when he did
that I'm like do you have asthma do you
need to go outside what's wrong with you
[Laughter]
it's all about communication
that's not communication of aggressive
and the best part is when after they'd
go you're like what's wrong and they're
like that [ __ ]
I like people where you never have to
guess that's how I like to me is like I
just tell you exactly how I feel at that
moment I'm feeling it otherwise [ __ ]
like Fester's
then that little side it becomes like
the loudest [ __ ] noise you've ever
heard like Phil's burger I think that's
the one thing that I learned the most
was like breakups is that communication
is such a big thing for me cuz I
remember when I was younger I was always
worried like oh my god is he mad should
we talk about this oh my gosh am bring
it up no I'm gonna keep it to myself oh
my god why is he so mad today you know
like so stressful it's very stressful
and like the more relationships I go
through the older I get and I'm just
like I think you know the other party
matures with age too so communication
becomes easier and then now it's just
like like like Nikki and whatever like
whenever there's something wrong like
hey I just wanna let you know there's
this yeah you're just like oh [ __ ] sorry
yeah that's I love that yeah love that
and I like that about our group we do
that'll say yeah yeah I have actually
because of our group and being like
around such mature people that's
actually taught me to like approach
situations the same way cuz I've always
been terrified of confrontation like
growing up I'm just I swallow that's how
I it that's how I'm in too deep tsk I
never actually speak my mind or like go
for what I feel is right for myself or
even acknowledge what what I want and
I'm just like oh is that other like like
yeah like a people-pleaser like just
like oh I don't want to like you put
others needs before you exactly or like
if someone else is in a bad mood I'll be
like oh my god I don't know what I did
but I'm gonna do everything you take
everything personally when it is like
that person's anger whatever they're
going through like that's not even
really your thing
like that's not about you if they're
angry or they're dealing with some [ __ ]
like that's their problem
person like personifying their issues
yeah well I remember there was a time
where TIFF and I were talking about
something where like somebody had like
hurt her feelings or done something and
as soon as she told me the situation I
was like that has nothing to do with you
I was like it literally has nothing to
do with you and kind of the way that I
see it is like sometimes when something
happens with somebody in it like I
almost see it as like bullets that come
at you but they're more so words and
sometimes you have to go straight up
like neo in the matrix you guys got them
and you have to look at all angles and
be like you know where is this coming
from
yeah that was really helpful that talk
that we had it was in Vegas and that was
first time
and I really like bonded like we cried
our eyes out that man it was beautiful
in the hotel room when we all had wine
that was part of it was like we were
eating pizza and for me I learned a lot
from you guys cuz you guys all gave such
great advice too but yeah like what you
were saying it's like you just have to
learn how to create a shield for
yourself especially if you're someone
like me that tends to like really like
put that responsibility of the world on
your shoulders where it's like is
everyone happy like is everyone good
like a people please they're like yeah
mom thing though you think you're like
really good at cuz you have to take care
of a child so you have ibly always like
do I have everything do I need a friend
I do anything wrong like happy is he
happy yeah like that's like the most
important thing are you happy but I also
I noticed that you are such an intuitive
person so that's a really it's a really
tough skill to build to like be able to
shield because you really like feel
other people's energies so even if
someone else is having a bad time it has
nothing to do with you like you take
that on and sometimes it's hard to
separate what's yours and what's theirs
yeah that's so true but I have noticed a
huge transformation she's no longer into
deep - oh yeah I can kill you have you
seen no but has been very like I
definitely have felt myself grow a lot
especially this year because I have
removed a lot of toxicity in my life and
it's been so liberating like I can
breathe in out like it's been amazing
yeah have you guys had any like
situations in the past year or so where
you had to choose to cut somebody out of
your life yeah and like I mean like yep
what like what happened like lives who
adored like in the past couple of years
well I mean like mine with the break-up
like I so I don't want to say that our
relationship was toxic but it wasn't
positive and it wasn't helping my life
and I was in it for so long so I felt
invested and I kept so Shannon Bodrum
has this thing that where she talks
about like
I'm like putting money into like a
gambling machine or something I'm
probably butchering it but she's like
you sat at the at the machine so long
like getting coins and you just want to
hit the jackpot right that's so you keep
putting you know coins in so I was doing
that for like five years with my
relationship and so I had to make the
choice to leave and it actually turned
out to be a great choice for both of us
so sometimes you're so scared because
you're like oh we invested so much and
like things are like we're supposed to
work they were supposed to make it work
or whatever but then when you sometimes
when you realize you cut someone out
it's just like oh my god I really really
needed that and honestly I lost not only
my mom this year and my relationship but
I also lost a really close friend this
year too so I've lost like three people
in the span of just one year and like I
I would think that it would be like the
worst year of my life but actually it's
been the best year of my life
think about me I'm like not that that's
Jesse different from like 12 months ago
like I was actually scrolling back and
looking at some text messages that I was
sending with this friend like from like
12 months ago and I was just like
reading like kind of just the way that I
used to speak the way that I used to
feel like just my energy everything was
just so negative and I was just always
so like uh and now I just feel so light
like you've been so positive more like
yeah I wish everyone knew like if you
could just make a couple of changes and
cut a few people out of your life a lot
can actually change for the better yeah
in like toxicant relationships
friendships environments it can
sometimes feel like you're under attack
and when your brain or your body feels
like it's under attack it fights back
and it's very stressful for you because
you feel like you always have your fists
up yeah and you it's like winds once the
next battle when's the next fight you
know and like I feel like I I went
through something kind of similar my old
roommate in Vegas she was my best friend
for five years I still love her to death
but when I moved out to LA about three
years ago she this is more of a thing of
like friends that ended up being in two
different places mentally like
emotionally financially just life paths
and when I moved out to LA she wasn't
happy for me
um and first it was oh I'm just joking
I'm just joking but then it turned into
you know fans would comment on my
Instagram and she would respond to a fan
there was one time where I had a photo
in a bikini and a fan was like saying I
looked great or something and she
responded to them and was like I don't
even know why she's in a bikini she
can't even swim like a mental like
mental health issues well your shows
like empathetic to the point where
you're like it's okay I mean she was
literally my best friend we were so
similar like we could talk on the phone
for hours there was like a warmth like
with each other we had like we were so
similar but she was so damaged and I
couldn't help her and there's a point
that I had to let go and I had to
realize like no matter what like I can't
hold myself back and my accomplishments
just because I don't want her to be mad
at me right true in it that was it was
really tough and so like we stopped
talking about we stop talking about a
year ago and I mean I I definitely miss
her but I don't miss I don't miss like
the the pain and the arguments right and
stuff like that and I had to do what's
best for me how do you feel since you
haven't spoken to her in a year um just
a little more like neutral like we
shared a lot of like love as friends and
I do miss that part of it but it's not
worth the toxicity absolutely not worth
it and also the stress of loving someone
so much that you can't help she was a
bad relationship a bad situation like
with her job and I for two years to help
and I didn't know how to help and so I
it's more so I had to lift that stress
off of myself I did that as well
with a friend of mine we were friends
since kindergarten
literally are in Mexico No
I was born and raised in Mexico Larry
anyway so um but yeah so this friend of
mine like like I said like since
kindergarten we were inseparable like
she was like my sister
it was insane like I I grew up in her
household like her family was my family
and slowly through the years she just
like she's a person of like extremity
like you mm-hmm
being straight extreme and on each side
of the spectrum so like like in high
school and in college I could was like
wild like party girl like going like
sleeping with other people like just you
know they'll be nights where we're like
we don't even know where she is like
wild wild yeah and and then like after
that like she went to the other end
where she was like super Christian like
I couldn't even play music in my car cuz
she'd say that's the devil's music like
it wasn't it was it was really really
what's the word extreme it was just like
really extreme so over the years like I
kind of we grew apart and I've just
tried to keep in touch with her here and
there and it's just really heartbreaking
because she has never like she stopped
maturing and growing up at like freshman
year high school like that like where
her mind stopped and not only that but
she actually does have like mental
health issues to the point where she had
to be like institutionalized for a
little bit should she the drugs yeah she
did and like and not just that but like
and I like I said I grew up with her
family but her family is insanely toxic
like they have like there's people and
her family there are drug addicts
there's other people that like just it's
just it's crazy so have much of and so
like it breaks my heart every time I I
get in touch with her again because I
really feel like I tried for so long for
so many years to like be the friend that
she needs cuz she she really doesn't
have a lot of
people in her life but every time I'm
with her I feel like my life force is
being sucked out of me like she's just
so it's just it's too much where I I
kind of had to make a decision just
recently maybe like in the last year or
two years to tell like just to be like
listen like I I love you I just can't
have you in my life it's just every time
we meet it's just too much and she
doesn't really it didn't really click
for her because till this day she'll
she'll call me at like almost every
other day and leave voicemails and like
and like she'll text me things like I'm
telling you like she's stuck in high
school cause she'll text me like hey I'm
walking to my grandma's house what are
you doing like I'm just bored and like
things like that where I'm like a
husband and a son of Grandma's for
cookies
I stopped responding now after I like I
spoke to her and I told her like listen
I love you I just don't feel like I'm
the person for you because I've tried to
help her like she's been in Community
College she's 30 now and she still has
not received not even an associate's
degree like it or like any sort of
profession and like it's just really sad
cuz I'm like I I tried to help her and
like get her into like different things
like when I was doing phlebotomy I'm
like dude you should do phlebotomy with
me and like I don't know like an actual
like very important breakup and within
the last year's or two and it was it was
a it was I think it's one of the eye if
not the hardest one I've been through
right I was with someone who I swore was
my soul mate like this was my best
friend I wanted kids with him like this
was because we like we had split up and
then we tried again and then this was it
I was still going through like a finding
myself process and knowing what I want
and what I'm worth and when we got back
together I was like okay yeah we can
work on things and stuff you know but
eventually I broke it off because it was
one of those like as much as I love you
why are we not taking it to next level
like we know we love each other but I
want to move in together I want to get
married I want to have kids like I
wanted way maybe you want to have right
that's a big thing to sacrifice that
[ __ ] yeah so and you know I was kind of
like where he going this is key he was
still pursuing his dreams so it didn't
seem viable you know and he was like
well I wish you would wait a couple more
years and stuff and I'm like I don't
have that time I want if I were to have
kids I want healthy kids I want to bring
this to the next level and I was like
what's your plan like what do you want
to do and stuff and then if he were to
give up his dreams for me then Iota
resented you - exactly so I like this is
probably the hardest decision of my life
and I told him I was like I love you
like you're my best friend I might lose
you because of this but I need to do
what's right for me yeah because I can't
live on someone else's timeline as much
as I love you so much you know so like
it broke his heart it broke my heart you
know but it's like like just said it
wasn't meant to be but it was meant to
happen yeah and I believe in multiple
soul mates like best friends are my soul
mates too you know
oh I believe in soul contracts that's
not this episode but what is a soul car
oh my god so a soul contract it's when
you are like you have some in your life
but things aren't quite working out but
you don't know why you can't quite get
rid of them it's because before you came
back to earth you guys made a soul
contract that they would help you with
your mission and you would help them
with their mission and then after like
when you do release that person that
means like you fulfilled each other's
that makes a lot that's cool
so I I heard that if you are
I can't transition this add a weddings
you know like you don't want it away are
you broke and in love did you know that
a wedding planner
I'm not kidding guys a wedding planner
cost about $5,000 really yeah that's a
reasonable person that's reasonable know
that oh I have I have on that I want to
spend that on my honeymoon and you want
to spend that on your honeymoon too so
save money by planning your wedding with
Zola that's right planning it with Zola
wedding planning is stressful is tiring
oh my one thing is really I'm not even
married and I know the whole time I'm
gonna be like does he still love me
while trying to check out these invites
wedding so what are we I wish we had
this when when I was planning my wedding
because I couldn't afford a wedding
planner and I haven't do that [ __ ]
myself and it was the most stressful
[ __ ] I've ever gone nikki is the most
organized like schedule oriented she
loves this [ __ ] and just on top of your
wedding day it's really insane imagine
someone like Gina trying to plan bro I
mean I hired a wedding from a planner
for my birthday birthday was a wedding
mix wedding planning easier less
stressful with wedding websites registry
invites and a guest list manager in all
place that's right when you send out
that email you gonna have a website like
Carrie and Rickey get married calm okay
okay you get free wedding website
designs we have the hi day I said we
that's how much I'm already on board I'm
like a piece of money Zola they have the
highest register they have the highest
rated registry of all registry for gifts
experiences honeymoon funds you can add
gifts to other stores you can sync a
registry that you already have and then
just have cookie you can't have a
wedding website and people can just be
like oh they want this this this this
here's my invite they have beautiful
affordable invites online and paper and
they'll also help you collect the
addresses track the online RSVPs with
their free guest list manager that's
awesome because I only my wedding if I
was a text I texted s stressful for your
guests I don't think I have it in one
place I don't think I even got a text it
was more like a you until wedding yeah
in Paris I see I should have had some
sure had Zola Zola has helped a million
couples get married and they're gonna
help you to because we broke and we
don't wanna pay for all this
JLo can't be taking all of our money
that was the wedding planner reference
sign up a Zola calm slash b tch today
and get your free personalized paper
sample then use code save 50 to get
50% off your CV 50% off it's right grot
I talk you broke you in love
Zola Zola calm slash b tch in promo code
save 50 semi wedding planning yeah good
luck dude wedding planning man I just
got flashbacks old I actually read one
time your soulmate is I think it's
similar maybe it's a soul contracts at
this concept is that your soulmate is it
necessarily the person you end up with
but it's the person that you meet it
could be the person you end up but it's
the person you have to meet to change
yourself to get yourself ready oh those
little contracts okay yes exactly what I
went through with him I felt like it
like he thought so this is really weird
I'm gonna open up real hard right now
let me see your butthole Gina let me see
that's dripping all right spread so me
mentally with the past like abuse that
I've been through when I was a kid sex
is completely a different thing for me
it is never emotional I don't correlate
sex with love or anything emotions right
and I didn't realize that was weird and
to like a few years ago right and I was
like oh wait cuz I always heard about
making love in movies like my friend was
like oh me and my boyfriend make love
and it was so beautiful that I cried I'm
like you guys are [ __ ] weird like he
cries during sex right I relate to that
yeah so I didn't know that was a thing
right until this one and then when that
happened I cried afterwards and only oh
my god this is what love is and it was
beautiful and then like he sat there and
he cried with me too and it was the most
incredible thing and I was like I think
you're my soul mate you know so that's
major
yeah I had no idea how to comprehend it
did he fix me or did he just show me
something that was there that I didn't
know that now you haven't covered it
yeah yeah so that's why I say like I
believe in multiple soul mates and he
was one of them he was meant to be there
for me too so I can learn about myself
and know that I am capable of being
completely fully 100% in love with
someone definite
yeah and it was such a big thing for me
so to let that go was such a painful you
know event in my life and I didn't know
how to handle it I was like I don't want
to feel guilty for wanting more for
myself and I'm sorry that I hurt you I
don't want to hurt you you know so that
was like a huge catalyst in my life and
it's taught me like this is what I want
in a relationship this is what love is
and I grew from that and now I know what
I'm looking for yeah that's like the
biggest thing that you can learn is like
knowing like through going what you hate
it or don't want you can learn what
you're looking for and also through
going through some things you did find
out you liked you can know what you're
looking for but I feel like you know if
you're going to everything's like a road
map like if you're going to New York
from Los Angeles if you didn't know
where you were going if you know you
wanted to go to New York you wouldn't
know when you got there yeah so at least
knowing like okay New York there's
Statue of Liberty there's like Times
Square there's all these like landmarks
okay I know when I got there yeah so
what that breakup mm-hmm I feel like it
was a very so the do you guys feel like
with breakups it gets a little bit
easier later on because you kind of
learn how yeah right how to deal with it
because when I was in my early 20s and I
broke up your girl went [ __ ] wild
dude just like right now it's more like
I'm optimistic I'm like I learned this
from this relationship I'm sad that it
ended but now I know more that's like a
big part of like why we kind of grow and
unfortunate side of when we see our
friends don't grow and like we see them
get stunted in their like teens or 20s
or whatever is that they're afraid to
kind of like let go of things too
because there's so much growth in being
able to let go of things and a lot of
people they'll stay in the same town
they won't let go of their high school
sweetheart they don't do any of this and
then they don't grow and that's why we
wind up like having to cut certain
people out because you see them stay
stunted so like it's it's hard and it
sucks but it's also very beautiful and
it's a part of life and it's something
that you can't avoid you have to be able
to let go of certain people in order to
get better at understanding life and
what you want out of life and understand
life just in general and a bigger
picture of like how it should be yeah so
when you're when you're
stock holding onto things it's like
you're not doing yourself any favors
you're not doing that other person any
favors either so yeah and you and I feel
like we generally tend to hold on to
these things out of comfort
yeah it's getting habit yeah I hope
because you really hope that things will
change and I think ultimately everybody
wants to grow and in order to grow you
have to go through periods of discomfort
mandatory and you know we're so
privileged to live out in a city like
this in Los Angeles inside such a kind
of cutthroat industry because we're
forced to grow we've we've all been
thrown into situations like that come
very quickly like every couple of months
that we suddenly have to deal with like
there are fires in our lives but when
you're out you're in your hometown
dating the same guy that you've been
with for six years with the same exact
friends hating the same family members
where's the discomfort where is the room
for growth where is the will to change
but you have to you have to just put
yourself out there you'll grow you'll
find [ __ ] badass ladies like these
like it it'll propel your life forward
to experience that discomfort I know a
lot of people ask I'm gonna switch the
subject a little bit a lot of people
always message me like how do you get
over a breakup do you guys have any
breakup tips or things that you do to
get over a breakup I know I don't
actually I feel like because I've been
on only in one relationship since I was
you know like 25 so it's been a long
time I've been dealing with just one
person and then going through one
breakup but I didn't break up until I
was like fully ready so when you're
fully ready and you fully know like
right what to expect and like you know
like this is gonna hurt but whatever
blah blah blah but like I need to move
on then it's just so much easier so like
if you get broken up with and you're not
ready for it and you're not like I
honestly wouldn't even know how cars or
I destroyed my own house like I feel
like I'm just
yeah like he chewed on me and then I'd
[ __ ] up my own house smart because
then you can't get sued yeah the same
thing I just went on like a [ __ ]
tornado spinning just like the mattress
was on the other side of the room I
don't know I'll tell this story I don't
know if anyone else has went to based
off of what not to do after blowing up
their phone
oh my god yeah I feel like we could
definitely get Tony's stock that I got
stopped creepy I was gonna check my
crazy thing that I did and like I feel
like I'm told so many stories about how
[ __ ] nuts I was at 18 but you know I
was in pain okay young also we all did
dumb [ __ ]
oh you're young it's so I feel like it's
so [ __ ] up but I'm just I'm sharing
don't do this so I was 18 and a half and
together
my very first apartment I actually had
another roommate which is his best
friend but my boyfriend he basically
lived there and eventually he was paying
like a couple hundred dollars rent just
to help out well we broke up but we
still live together so I moved back in
with my parents and let the guys stay
there for the last two months the least
just to make sure everything was getting
done I would come by at the end of the
month to pick up the utility payments
and the rent and I come in one day and
I'd left my bed there at the house and
like it was a nice [ __ ] bed and
mattress and I [ __ ] go into my old
room and there's a whole box of condoms
and like a open condom packet in the
trash can next to the bed for me this
was my bad dog like disrespectful and
riot I was I let him sleep there like I
yeah what the [ __ ] just heard the bed
I'm tired
I took a marker
I wrote on the wall who are you question
mark it like permanent mark like to the
girl yeah in case she [ __ ] comes back
oh I thought it was to the guy like who
are you like who do you know I wrote
that on her because dude if I were to
know he has AIDS yeah but I don't know
why I thought that that was like the
right thing to do but that's what I
wrote it but like if I came to [ __ ] a
dude and I come in and own permanent
marker like in a woman's handwriting it
says who are you I'd be like I need to
get the [ __ ] like you can't leave now oh
my god what did I get into yeah that was
that was like my crazy thing and he was
a she's [ __ ] crazy and I was like you
[ __ ] somebody in my bag I don't want
that back that's actually not even that
bad you're telling me like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] or something I don't but I just
remember that's what that's very mild
though for what you couldn't repair for
the worst yeah yeah Golf Club into a
wall yeah when I was 19 I got out my
boyfriend inside cheated on me like
multiple times and like the girl didn't
know about me I got connected with her
because she was friends with their
cousins with my friend and they were all
talking whatever and he denied it so I
drove to his house like look I'm the
happy [ __ ] when I Drive like you
started to spin oh man yeah so like I
took a golf club to the wall and his
mirror and his friend called me up he's
like Gina I I just found out what
happened please chill but here's the
thing my craziness I had a method to it
because I knew I didn't want to get sued
so I didn't go for the crazy [ __ ] cuz he
was a video editor and I did it and I
could have dumped all that footage into
it oh but I was like good for you
maintain some morals that's other people
that don't eat you know their wedding
footage for it that's great one time do
you try to break up with me and this
might be how you get a man oh yeah I
never heard this story alright this was
right before our one-year anniversary
like I said like I want to get you two
because like I've talked about the
arrows before but some people haven't
heard the story and I feel like everyone
has heard it but I'll get there yeah so
he tried to break up with me for I know
perfect that's perfect but just
complimenting my breasts anyway for that
so yeah we had been fighting little
fights like almost like every little
thing just like caused an argument we're
like so we were in the garage and
something I don't even know how it got
brought up is so stupid we were arguing
about like toothpaste because he always
leaves the cap off the toothpaste and if
[ __ ] pisses me off yeah and then he
got into an argument about like how I
only brushed my teeth once a day I used
to brush it boys today and I was like
well you don't floss [ __ ] but we get
back up to the apartment and he goes I
can't do this anymore oh and I was like
what do you mean me neither like I
[ __ ] hate this and he was like he's
like yeah I need a break and I was like
like long everything off the coffee
table and flipped it and shattered and
didn't mean to break that's okay that
was that and then I just ran to the
bathroom and cried and like curled into
a ball and was like putting all my walls
ever coming back in and then he came in
the bathroom and he hugged me and he was
like I will never leave you so I think I
scared the [ __ ] we did and then explain
for the people who haven't heard yeah so
he dude that's how I feel like [ __ ]
Steve is my soul mate because no one
else could handle that [ __ ] like any
time I've had a boyfriend where like
they've seen that final dark side where
I'm like at my worst you know they're
just like scared off and they're like
run away obviously like it's like a lot
you know to have someone like flip a
coffee table or whatever but he he came
in he just like hugged the [ __ ] out of
me and then he just like made me feel
like he has my back completely and he's
like yo we both want the same things
right like we both you know we both love
each other we both like have fun with
each other we had the same sense of
humor we have the best time we're best
friends like why isn't it working and we
found that there were like little things
like how your ex used to sigh like it
wasn't next we were just seeing each
other he doesn't deserve that [ __ ]
sigh or dude so little things had built
up subconsciously and neither of us knew
that they were really building up we
just had like little things here and
there that we held onto that we didn't
think we're big enough deal to like
bring up which is why indicate exactly
which is why I'm so big on just like
immediately saying it now instead of
like letting [ __ ] build up but we found
that like little things would trigger
each other just because like we hadn't
gotten the deeper [ __ ] out and so we
were hanging on to stuff from like a
year ago plus we had both gotten
together right after being dumped from
our previous relationships which were
both really toxic you're carrying that
yeah
was kind of like getting projected on to
each other so we one-by-one like thought
about like something that we had been
holding on to like all the things that
we ever didn't bring up and we
one-by-one like pulled imaginary arrows
out of our body so I'd be like okay this
one time you know you compared me to
your ex and you thought I was like her
and I'm not like her and that really
hurt me and then he would be like I'm
really sorry I did that I didn't mean it
and then we would break the arrow over
yeah and we would throw it away and
honestly I don't remember any of those
arrows anymore I don't even remember
what they were because it just like
completely gone and relieved and we
haven't fought since I mean we've had
like an argument yeah they're like we
like actually like like to argue like a
real issue you know and we haven't like
gotten into like a heated argument like
that since and we've been together seven
years so I feel like if you can really
talk through like that and then get over
it those people are meant to stay in
your life thrid of it
speaking of talking you know sometimes
you can't talk to the person themselves
but you can talk to a therapist a
therapist with what an app you have
called talk space so talk space is an
app where you can speak to an actual
real trained therapist over like text
message or you can do voice message or
you can even video message them
depending on your plan talk space online
therapy gives you a convenient and
affordable way to improve your mental
health and it pairs you with one of
5,000 more than 5,000 licensed
therapists on your needs and preferences
so what you do is you go on there and
you take a little quiz and you talk
about what you want to work through and
then it'll match you with like three
therapists and you can choose one it can
change that therapist anytime and it
gives you a month of any time access for
the price of one in-person therapy
session so it's like super affordable
and I like it because instead of waiting
and like holding everything in just to
meet someone for a month or once a week
or so yeah I can text them like at 4:00
in the morning well I'm going through
something right now and then they check
their phone like maybe like twice
day five days a week and they respond to
you immediately so you have like yeah
cuz sometimes by the time you make it to
your in office appointment you don't
feel those feelings anymore it's like I
don't know I have to recall like how I
felt when I was at my worst and even if
you don't want a text you can just voice
messages that's what I do at four in the
morning like a four-minute long voice
message to my therapist um so it's
clinically proven in one academic study
talk space users reported a 50% drop in
anxiety after three months and 80% of
participants in another study said talk
space was as effective or more effective
than in-person therapy all your messages
are encrypted and it protects your
information and it's absolutely 100%
confidential I personally use this
myself and it's been a huge help shots
Maria I love you um so I mean we all
need help navigating life's ups and
downs whether it be relationships
friendships personal stuff that you just
can't talk about so anyone else talk
space offers the support you need an
affordable price our listeners can get
$100 off their first month by using the
code b-tch at talk space comm match with
a therapist for a fraction of the price
and traditional therapy at talk space
comm or download the app so make sure
you use the code b-tch and get $100 off
your first month well it's always like
discount promo code C BT so going back
to what you were saying Gina about how
like when you're young you just like do
a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] because you just
don't know how to you have those
emotions and you don't know how to
handle them because you never been
through that situation before so you
don't know where to place them I feel
like everybody at one point in their
life is gonna encounter a toxic
relationship whether it be with a
friendship or with a boyfriend or
girlfriend or even in business like I've
had like just like really I've learned
like what I don't do business well with
anymore but they're all like they're all
just like tools that you get to put in a
bucket so that you can like use so that
you develop non-negotiables and like you
learn okay this is what I will no longer
stand for like my ex used to Gaslight me
all the time I didn't even [ __ ] know
that was a thing before but he would
like
change what happened like go back in
time and like say that what happened
didn't happen he made me feel crazy as
[ __ ] and he was so convincing to or I
was actually like I have a pretty good
memory but I like I don't know like I
trust him and he's good and I will never
do that [ __ ] again yeah I always tell
myself when it comes to any like break
up with any relationship is I kind of
look at the bright side and the big big
picture and it's kind of like it's kind
of far-fetched and kind of weird but I
always say okay so I'm going through
this terrible breakup and my heart's
broken I'm so sad but it's really
beautiful that I get to live a life
where I feel these emotions the fact
that I even get to live this long to
feel these emotions because a lot of
people don't have the luxury of going
through this you know like I mean some
people die young and they don't get to
feel love and heartbreak and stuff so
that's like my big picture like I'm glad
that in this path in life I get to feel
these emotions and if I think that this
person was great now imagine when I find
the one yeah so that's like so positive
do you know Thanks so that's what I do
and it's like my healing process like
it's it's a part of life like just said
this is a part of life that you have to
go through and it sucks but it's
actually beautiful that's been
collecting a palette of emotions yeah
that's true I've never been broken up
with I'm just trying to say like I like
what is this like broken up with my
heart broken okay I have without being
left yeah without being left and and so
like that does get really rough but then
what gets me through that is by telling
myself like okay well this is this is
something I'm meant to go through
because like what we're talking about
earlier it's like you know through
discomfort is there's growth and so
that's what helps me be okay with it and
also especially more recently and like
maybe this year I've also learned how to
take responsibility for for part of it
too because not everything is going to
be one-sided and that's kind of hard to
see sometimes because yes people can be
toxic malicious evil
whatever but you also have to take
responsibility in like what you like
your participation in that as well so
that that has helped me grow and mature
a lot recently where I'm like well I did
let that slide and I didn't do my like
you know like I didn't draw like the
line in the sand said like listen and
you're not gonna pass here like I
Stuckey was like up to here is like
where you're gonna stop and then like
that's the responsibility that I had to
take about myself
and take care of myself and also take
care of the the relationship because not
like I said not everything it's gonna be
one-sided so I have learned to grow out
of that like victim mentality because I
definitely have been of [ __ ]
victim my whole life and I'm just
recently I just got tired of it I'm like
listen I'm I'm sick and tired of being a
[ __ ] victim like what the [ __ ] am i
doing that's getting me to this place
and like it can you take responsibility
for it you know so that's how you - yeah
and I like a lot of people say like
after a break it was like oh it's such a
waste of my time well a lot and I I
don't like looking at the way if you
learn from it
if you grew from it if you find
something that this is not what I'm
gonna deal with anymore then it wasn't
waste of time this was meant to happen
you've learned and this is a growth for
you yeah I even said that in my wedding
vows cuz like that like growing up my
whole life I think I'm even saying hey
baby way I think I'm here singing
verbatim but like my whole life I had
always felt like moments that I I really
regretted and I'm just like [ __ ] well I
wish I could go back in time I used this
gets really dark but I used to when I
was really little I used to wish and
pray that there was some sort of time
machine that could go back in time and
prevent my parents from meeting like
that's how [ __ ] dark
yeah I would have just like come back
while she was pregnant put in a roller
coaster
you want to shake baby but yeah like I
used to really regret my life like
hardcore and that's why like during my
wedding vows like that's I remember that
morning like taking a shower and like
thinking about like why do I love this
man like what like you know what why
like what is it and it really like I
realize like you know everything I went
through in my life like literally every
bad thing that's happened to me every
good thing like it led me to that moment
and like I was really happy and I mean
I'm still I'm still pretty happy but
like yeah so that that really made me
realize like you need to go through what
the [ __ ] you're going through because
it's gonna get you where you need to be
yeah I was just talking to my dad
yesterday on the phone and I was like
just kind of realizing like I was like
God my life is so weird like I'm living
like in you know Los Angeles I have like
a podcast now I'm like kind of starting
to like date very interesting people
yeah cuz you never planned to be like an
on camera person but you're embracing
yeah but the point I was trying to make
to my dad was I was like I was just like
can you like remember like when I was
younger like the [ __ ] that I was in like
I was in this kind of like shitty town
dating these shitty guys I remember
after um you remember the guy I told you
about that was cheating on me with the
girl he's drugged out of yeah so before
before like that whole other story there
was a time where I like when I first
found out he was cheating with that girl
where she called me somehow she got my
number she called me and I could hear
him talking in the background so it was
a voicemail from her phone with him
there and so I was living three hours
from him at the time cuz I had just
moved from my hometown to San Antonio so
I get that phone call and I got in my
car and I drove three hours to go drive
and it's so violent can you imagine like
me being just so wrapped up in so much
[ __ ] yeah and like caring so much
about these toxic people and then now
fast forward like ten years and it's
like I had to go through that to get to
the emotional maturity that I'm at now
we're like if someone if I the guy say
I'm dating someone now and then I find
she gonna hear a voice mail of him
talking blah blah blah blah blah oh yeah
I don't really love her blah blah that's
fine I would just like pick up the phone
just click end and then I would never
see him again and yeah I would never
[ __ ] waste my time to drive three
hours you know so it's like you have to
go through these things to like not care
anymore cuz you're just like okay I
really see that I just really didn't
mean that I'm not sure yet I'm not sure
I need to let like it would be if I was
invested in that person and I really
loved them still and that happened I
think I would need to let outrage
somehow whether it's in my own apartment
to my own pillows
I might scorch the earth dude like earth
to yeah I think you've actually grown a
lot more than you realize so you would
probably be like I'm saying if whoever
my date next I hope so girl that Steve
was cheating on me with called me and I
heard him in the background I would
[ __ ] light it on fire come over and
help you thank you cuz I've gone through
that now I'm like okay well now I know
he's worthless he's not worth my time a
lot of people that when you've gone
through a bunch of shitty people whether
it be like people you've dated or
friends you've had a drop or like
business partners and whatnot and then
you go through a bunch of shitty
obstacles all the small [ __ ] it does not
matter yeah there's more there's more
guys out there there's more friends out
there and you know it because you get
over it and then you go find yeah almost
that replacement it sounds [ __ ] up but
once you find that replacement like a
few times then you realize I don't have
to put up with this yeah there is no
reason to fight for this there's no
reason to like like put my thoughts into
this like this person like why the fun
that's the most important part is
learning to love yourself enough to
realize that you can do better that you
deserve better me there is better out
there there's like nothing's the end of
anything like there's so many people and
so many opportunities and so much life
to live that you don't have to hold on
to anything even people that this is the
last person that ever gonna make me feel
this way this is the last person I'm
gonna connect with you so much it's like
no it's not seven billion people there
dude
fine there you have like whenever I feel
like and I know I don't even think I
actively think about this I think it's
been passive actually because you said
that and it rings true it's like
whenever something bad happens I'm like
okay I just got to get through this
because I have a lot of life to live and
through this bad thing there's gonna be
eight good things so let's get through
the bad thing let's and move on like
that's like yeah that's very much how
I've been through things and I think
that when we have a lot of heart like
when you have a lot of hardships do not
be afraid embrace it because it's just
making the rest of your life easier yeah
yeah okay you know what's interesting to
is I think that when you were saying
like oh I've been through this
experience and now that that that that
wouldn't affect me the same way anymore
I feel like I could say that about
things that happen outside of like my
inner circle but I think like if anyone
in my inner circle because there's that
like trust and like like like love
that's been you know there I feel like
that's the only time where it still
would affect me you know I mean I think
it definitely still hurts but it's yeah
I'm not gonna put the energy into it
that I used to I so like I'm gonna cry
I'm gonna whatever you know I'll be sad
for a few weeks but it's like I'm not
gonna get in my car and drive three
hours I'm true like to be like okay how
do I fix this or what
[ __ ] I'll make a phone call I'll return
your call
you got a week after that and then I'm
not driving I'm not putting up yeah it's
just like yeah you remember like being
so just like ruminating constantly like
oh my god there or is he cheating he's
gonna break up with me or like what am I
gonna do now like and it's just like why
do I don't have that energy I need to
hear what happened when you drove these
three hours I'm trying I don't think I
could find him he was with her and I and
I couldn't know I didn't know where she
lives so I wound up going to his
cousin's house and like waiting for him
or something and then confronted him
later but I didn't get what I wanted out
of it you know I was like where are you
[ __ ] and I couldn't find him
nothing I want to say I'm not mature
person but I'm taking at least one
kneecap
I never actually physically hurt anybody
but I mean there's some walls we did
some damage no you were like I've never
physically hurt you yeah we have wood
taut which time if the girl knew about
it you know
Oh actually no the one that after like
we tried to work it out and I was still
piss and he goes I know you want to hit
me I'm like boy you have no [ __ ] oh
not like that no I've just been in
fights before beating my dude you have
no idea he goes and like keep in mind
this was 19 year old immature Gina and
then like I was sitting on top of him in
bed because we're just talking don't
worry like I'm just sitting there
talking I know I know you wanna I know
what hit me right now I'm like oh you
have no idea he goes just do it and I
did well i socked him in the mouth dude
Wow open or closed oh yeah I'm like
that's not okay I'm like nice consensual
it was that's true and it did feel good
but now I'm just like I don't I don't
know if that was a good idea or not but
and then later on he told people like oh
I fell I was like oh my god and I'm no
he's a real [ __ ] like I don't do that
now I can't bring myself to do that but
at the time 19 year old immature Gina
that was like it was in full rage yeah
that was you think that but like putting
pain on someone else is gonna make you
feel better but really I think you just
like you create more pain within
yourself and then you carry the faculty
or someone physically but I know cuz I'm
sitting here like I think I would love
that the time is just right you know
yeah I mean later on it just didn't work
out at all but it that relationship
taught me a lot dude a lot and that's
like I said never a waste of time
true so if you're going through a
breakup right now I think it's really
healthy to look at to have that
perspective of like what did I learn
from this slick right down like all the
things that you like from the
relationship
and then all the things that like you
could [ __ ] live without yeah and then
don't settle on though that list of
things that you could live without
because for me I felt like I was
repeating the same pattern like I would
constantly like getting relationships
where I liked like they had a certain
sense of humor and like we you know
related on a deeper level and then like
they were just really shitty people and
I'm like why do I keep falling in love
with [ __ ] and it was because like I
kept like settling on this one or two
things that were really that's not too
bad I can deal with that you know like
that like yeah yeah exactly yeah people
give you that set speech that's like
well you're always gonna have to settle
in some area you know they give you the
like you know what then you don't really
so you know you definitely have to
settle here and there but not on the
things that you can't like can do
without you know like there are certain
things that I just will not do in a
relationship or I made the decision as
to never do in a relationship again and
then I did an example um so like the no
communication yeah like if I'm texting
you if you're like I'm on my way over
and they're like I'm on my way over and
then they don't show up
it's [ __ ] not okay that's not okay
yeah that used to happen all the time
and I would just forgive it cuz I'm like
okay well let's sing whenever and like
my time is unimportant I don't want to
get him mad by you know come over like
respect yourself yeah time all that [ __ ]
I think that does come with like a level
of self love and self respect and like
knowing like what you're worth and what
you bring to the table which when I was
in my young twenties I just really
didn't know I just really wanted whoever
I liked to like me back and so I would
just bend over backwards and people
please and then I would be confused when
they would screw me over yeah dude I
think that if you're ever saying to
yourself or to somebody else in a
conversation the phrase I don't want
them to be mad at me that basically says
there's a thing that I don't want to do
but I know that this person will be
upset if I don't do what they want
basically yeah like you clearly probably
don't want to do it you're even saying
that and you need to look at that
situation a little bit deeper it's okay
to be selfish sometimes it's okay to
cancel things it's okay to to kind of I
have to do this at work all the time I
have to
set people's expectations you know and
in you and it's all about putting those
boundaries down for yourself and how are
you gonna put those boundaries down if
you don't know what you want what you
want if you're just doing what everyone
else wants to avoid conflict or two
people please then you don't get to
understand yourself and you don't
understand what makes you happy and what
makes you feel fulfilled and what makes
you move through the day 100 like just
[ __ ] I did oh that like crazy because
that's been my whole life yeah like my
entire life I'm just like I don't know
what makes me happy yeah I don't know
what I like and I feel like we end up
cutting out some of those toxic people
that are holding those things over our
head where we're afraid to make them mad
you know and then we get rid of those
people and then you're like I'm free
yeah like I feel like these chains like
off of you it really does feel like that
yeah and I mean I think everyone gets to
everyone tries to talk to whoever the
person is that's kind of like this kind
of you know pulling these puppet strings
for them and when you get to a point
when you realize like you've exhausted
all of your options snip snip snip
you're done like you're done I learned a
lot from I had like I had older
girlfriends who are my mentors when I
was younger and a lot of it also comes
with age too yeah
I remember I was 25 I was going through
a relationship problems and they were in
their 30s already and they're like you
know as you get older you don't have
time for that [ __ ] anymore you lay
your cards out this is what I want this
way I don't deal with and if they're not
about it then that's it be and you just
and with mature people would be like
okay yeah I see that this is what I want
what I don't want and you figure that
out and you don't go through the whole
like put it out on day one okay one dude
yeah I think that and I think it coming
with age also comes from it comes from
experience yeah like at 25 I've dealt
with some [ __ ] but at 35 in that 10 year
span I'm gonna lose people I'm gonna
find people I'm gonna lose jobs I'm
gonna switch careers I'm gonna do this
this isn't this and then at 35 I don't
have time for your [ __ ] yeah I don't
have the time the energy for it and
that's why sometimes you'll find people
that are insanely mature at 22 cuz
they've been through a lot date and they
don't like you know and then at 32 it's
kind of like the same thing or sometimes
you'll meet people at 30 that have been
in their own bubble and they haven't
yeah there's another big thing like cuz
I get a lot of messages and I'm sure we
all do from girls who are like oh my god
I just found out my boyfriend was
cheating on me like well my whole life
is ruined I'm depressed like now I want
to [ __ ] die like buh-buh-bah so I
kind of want to address some of that a
little bit before we go [ __ ] baby
it's honestly like once you realize that
it has nothing to do with you and that
your self-worth is not tied to what
someone else does it's gonna get easier
so people are gonna hurt you no matter
what like there's you can't avoid that
like maybe this guy did some really
fucked-up [ __ ] he [ __ ] your best
friend in your bed like you know like
there's gonna be fucked-up [ __ ]
happening to all of us so I just really
want to put it out there like people
need to remember like whatever they do
is not a real reflection of you it's not
a reflection of your value it's it's
really has nothing to do with you so you
don't even mind in there and ponder like
was I not good enough for like what
should I do what could I have done
differently or like why did he do this
to me like why me like why me it's like
it's how you it's not you yeah that's a
really good reminder because not only do
you do that but like kind of like that
thing I mentioned in a previous episode
we're like as a child you subconsciously
you don't know you're doing this but
like when they hear other people talk
[ __ ] about their parent like they
already are they're like well I came
from this parent so I must also be a bad
person but like so then when your
boyfriend's cheating on you you're like
well I deserve it it's my fault that
this happened to me or like how like you
know yeah because you you attach
yourself like that yeah so the good
reminder it's not your fault when people
hurt you and don't do the whole I'm
gonna kill myself your eye does not
worth someone else's yeah yeah and on
the other hand too like on the other
side if you tell someone if you break up
with me I'm gonna kill myself if there's
people in your life right now like
really take a look at your circle of
people that you are in contact with on a
daily basis and if there's someone that
like gives you that pit in your stomach
when you think of them maybe that's a
toxic person that you need to cut out of
your life and sometimes it's hard if
it's family
oh yeah it's family especially an Asian
upbringing Souls like well it is your
family like no no no I don't care like
yeah Asian upbringing is are always like
well it's your blood you know your
family and
yeah you're my family I don't gotta be
around you like right though yeah
Mexicans are like that too and you cut
out a lot of my family and they make
excuses and like dismiss a lot of things
that terrible family members do just
because that's your family like no if
it's a toxic member the family you can
cut them out too yeah that's fine and
you don't have to follow someone else's
rules just because they say it's your
thing that thing again because you're
connected through blood you feel like
you have some sort of responsibility to
keep them in your life it's your life
that's right all right thank you so much
for watching and listening guys and if
you have a story you'd like to share
with us we love reading your comments so
leave us a comment and subscribe
subscribe subscribe subscribe rate us
five stars shout out to our sponsors
today we have a talk space make sure to
use code b-tch to get $100 off your
first month when you go to talk space
calm promo code b-tch and missoula if
you're planning a wedding holy balls you
need this service if you ain't loaded
Zola calm slash b tch today you get a
free personalized paper sample and use
code save 50 to get 50% off your save
the dates solocom slash b tch we'll see
you next time